make use of five things before five
things come
what is your health yeah before
your illness
yeah your health and another one
actually whatever one is your youth
before your old age so in many ways
you'll
fill in two aspects of prophetic advice
foreign
this is day two
this is the pool day and i'm here joined
with the big man
i'll talk about this man
[Music]
so in today's installment uh what we are
going to be doing is a pool day so it's
for people that are guests it's for
people that are you know really have a
busy lifestyle and they really want to
get every muscle group completed their
split right three day split push ball
legs and today's one is the poor one as
i just said and we're gonna be doing um
a complete back session and biceps
starting with the compounds then
isolating the muscles and uh yeah we're
just gonna kill it it's gonna be based
on muscle hypertrophy trying to put on
some good size maintain strength and uh
just really enjoy the session i'm gonna
make that solo about games that's it man
can i make this all right yes well let's
see what we can do let's see if you guys
can keep up with the chat
[Laughter]
so stay tuned watch the exercises
carefully and follow the routine the
shuttle and you'll make some uh
silverback gains like
like him and him yeah yeah before we
start the main compounds we're going to
be starting with some dynamic stretching
it's extremely important that you warm
up your lower back in particular your
whole posterior chain because we'll be
doing some heavy lifting with the
dentist let's go first thing i love to
do is uh a nice i call it window wipers
but follow me
lay on your back
knees up hands wide and try to drop your
knees from side to side it's a great way
to really stretch the lower back you do
dynamic stretching when warming up and
you do the static stretching at the end
so do about 20 reps
two sets
all right last one we're going to do is
another nice low back stretch lay on
your back hands across your knees and
trying to pull your knees to your chest
all right guys first exercise that we're
going to be doing on this pool day is in
my opinion the king of all exercises
alongside the squats but it's a deadlift
so this will be the major compound that
we're going to be doing i want to
like really put emphasis on how
important it is for you guys to really
watch your phone when you're dead
lifting i myself have learned the hard
way back in a few years ago i've hurt my
back many times so now i've i like to
think i've perfected the form so this is
how we're going to do it the few
mistakes that people make they do touch
and go reps touching gorillas gonna give
you the tendency to shoot your hips up
so i'll just demonstrate how i would how
i'll do it as i'm showing you so
feet quite narrow a bit more narrower
than shoulder width you want to get your
hands on either side of your body on the
outside of your knees so what you want
to do before lifting up i do alternating
grip
so you want to be here take a deep
breath it's so important to tighten up
your core engage your core before you
lift so what you want to do imagine
you're breaking the bar engage your lats
take a deep breath
engage the lats and then lift full
explosive control it on the way down
let it fully hit the ground reset take a
new breath
explosive on the way up control it down
deep breath
now ladies and gentlemen this is a
deadlift
initially let me see what that form is
saying
lovely rep just a bit more emphasis on
your chest coming up first not your hips
there we go much better on the way down
keep it together drop your hips a little
bit more on the way down
drop your hips more there we go much
better keep your chest sticking out like
the whole time even when you're going
down yeah try and keep you you want to
see your chest in the mirror at all
times so one thing i want to add i'm
guilty of it myself is uh when you're
dead lifting you want to try and keep
your neck neutral of your spine so you
might see me in this video doing it but
it's just a habit but you don't want to
have your neck pointed up too much
because you could strain your neck but
you want to try and keep your your neck
neutral with your spine so you're coming
up together and just keeping it tight
[Applause]
and then we'll be doing about four major
working sets
drop the hips as you come down
good job stop stop stop stop stop stop
okay
you need to drop your hips as you're
coming down when the ball passes your
knee bro you need to drop bend the knees
and sit into your hips yes exactly yeah
okay just to take the strain out i'll go
back here we can be low back okay let's
try again come on give me three more
reps okay
stand with your chest don't let your
hips shoot up let's go again
sit into your hips sit yes
much better
let's go again sit into your hips
good mind look straight don't look at me
let's go
so one of the main things in regards to
muscle hyper if you wanted to gain
muscle is you want to do progressive
overload you want to overload the muscle
and try and keep a good rep range so
working sets now got four plates on here
gonna aim for about five reps maybe more
but um
yeah just enjoy it and make sure the
form is perfected we'll be doing about
three to four workout sets on this and
you want to be at around eighty percent
of your one rep max it's a good place to
be out for your working sets let's go
is
all right guys
as you just saw
instead of this platform in it just so i
can say i'm a bit taller but anyways um
martial are strong but as you guys can
see the form is not what you guys should
follow
right now so uh the form could be a lot
better he's rounding his lumbar spine
he's shooting his hips up first okay
but other than that obviously the
strength is there but guys never go
heavier and chase numbers if you haven't
pat in the form okay this is a good
point well i've actually hurt my bike
before many times my club i've done it
was ironically it was not actually going
back it was doing something else it
could happen bro because it is it's the
same mechanics you're not if you're not
bracing your core properly and you're
pulling and that causes an extra
extension of the muscle fibers and bulk
you pull the muscle absolutely don't do
that your weighted pull-ups
uh if you find normal pull-ups easy then
just do weighted pull-ups these will
really bring out your lats we're gonna
do about four sets
eight to twelve reps
[Music]
peace
so next exercise for mid back and lats
four sets of ten reps which exercise
what's your size i don't even remember
the name see the rose yeah
[Music]
all right guys
when you train
push yourself when you go to work at
literally 80 to 90 of your one rep max
not all the time most of the time
because you really want to
basically push yourself
give it a little hold so this was the
last exercise that we're doing a good
way to finish it up i like to always
superset the last back exercise with
some sort of pullover so it's a cable
pull over primarily targets your laps
and just want to show you guys how we do
it right here
put it in keep your arms fairly straight
right there you want to throw it in
stretch squeeze
it
squeeze you don't want to do this
because it's going to become a tricep
extension so you want to be here
angle of your arm is fixed
squeeze it into your belly button
squeeze
[Music]
um obviously you're super setting so
whatever how many sets you're doing on
the exercise before just superset it
with this
so with this one you don't have to go
super heavy
keep it a bit lower so you can control
it and you want to keep your back almost
straight slightly maybe even tilted
forward and you want to bring it right
into your waist
all right guys just want to add one last
thing we need for example when it comes
to training is um to an extent on
certain exercises it's okay to sacrifice
a little bit of form if it means you can
force out a few more reps having said
that never do on deadlifts or squats or
these kind of big compound exercises
because the risk of injuries is
absolutely not worth it something like
this you can tend to roll a little bit
but just don't be too excessive and lean
all the way back
so now just for the video i'm going to
stack this machine out charlotte don't
hurt myself
and uh yeah
[Music]
come on keep going
keep going all the way in all the way in
come on
moving on to biceps straight bar kills
again it's very important to not swing
when you're doing it keep your elbows by
your side and make sure your elbows are
not moving from position either again
when we start going heavier the form
might get
[Applause]
[Music]
aiming for about 12 to 16 reps form make
sure you're not swinging guys
how did you find that guys
amazing session honestly
deadlifts were great i could have gone a
bit heavy i'm sure you could have gone
heavier but guys nobody's about
technique right his form was a bit
it's good to have
an example of how not to do something
okay there you go the guy who kept
making mistake in his prayer with the
professor
yeah yeah exactly yeah sometimes you
need like you know you've got the a star
answer the teachers to do this with you
right give you the a style so like my
type of ones and they give
[Laughter]
so you see how not to do it you know
yeah so yeah that's good number i'm
happy that you actually done it with me
because it wouldn't have made sense to
go heavier and and risk an injury right
deadlifts like for example of any
exercise deadlifts and squats be sure
that your form is patterned literally 10
out of 10 because it's not i made up for
it right in other forms he made up for a
bicep curls his biceps are a bit
stronger than mine
well it doesn't it well maybe it looks
like that when i'm when i'm cutting away
but it doesn't matter
you do surprise me with your strength
though
absolutely i mean
all right well thank you very much guys
for making sure that you know you
subscribe to this man here for more
because i'm not going to be doing these
videos all the time what is your youtube
channel it's just my name
and my instagram is silverback
underscore aj how are you
mine is strong believers
strong.believers on instagram and just
strong believers on youtube uh we've got
some workouts on there for full full
body workouts
cool that's fantastic and obviously you
guys know
hit that subscribe button
but i'm not even gonna tell you to do
that because you should have already
done it a long time to go and shame on
you if you haven't
seen